hey there YouTube my name is Martin
McGovern and you are joining us or ask a
career coach with Udacity thank you so
much for coming out and joining the
livestream today it's Thursday February
21st and we're going to be collecting
your questions and getting into how to
help you with your job search as we go
thank you again for joining us if you
have as you join us we have our kickoff
question of the day and it's going to be
about how to prepare for a phone
interview and behavioral interviews in
general we also as you join the chat
here are curious where you're joining us
from in the world and you know little
unique question would you have for
breakfast
today I had an egg and sausage sandwich
with bitter granola and alumnae coffee
so I give us a shout let us know where
you're at what time it is and you know
what you're what you're munching on in
your part of the world we're going to
give a few minutes here for folks to
join the chance we'll be officially
getting rolling on everything at 2:05
central time which is where I am but in
about four minutes for everyone else
please start adding in your questions to
the chat we have Karen there helping us
out she'll be forwarding all of your
questions on to me so that we can go
deep into each one of the topics that
you want answered for your job search so
as we all join together today I'll be
taking a look here to see where are
y'all coming from and what's on your
mind
looks like we have Karthik from India he
said peanut crackers and mousse Elliot
for breakfast sounds like a pretty great
combo peanut crackers sound amazing
we got Ottawa Canada thanks for joining
us Steph we got on
from Germany thanks for joining us on
Dre's ooh coffee and oats in Canada
loving it
oh we got folks joining us from India
first questions coming in I like it
please add all of your career questions
into the chat and Karen will be
forwarding them my way to dig in during
our conversation we got more more folks
joining from India Brazil Germany
Kurdistan we're LT all coming from will
be getting started here in just a couple
of minutes thank you again for joining
us we're really excited to get into the
questions that you have today and help
you move forward in your job search
give us a shout let us know where you're
joining from and put some questions
career questions in the comments I'll
begin to them in just a bit
Venezuela Northwest Florida Egypt we had
some more questions I like it
right we're gonna be jumping in at just
a minute the first thing I want to do is
just say thank you to everyone who's
coming back from a previous session
we've had we've had quite a few of these
ask a career coach sessions every single
Thursday here on YouTube and I just want
to give a huge shout out to those of you
who have been with us along for this
ride asking questions and engaging in
the comments and helping each other out
along the way a lot of times I don't
have all the answers and so it's great
for us to be able to help each other in
the chat as well one thing that I'm not
as well their son is a technical side of
things I am a career coach but my
background is primarily in marketing for
a development promotion things of that
sort so I'm really good at helping me
figure out how to build a network how to
reach out to people how to connect how
to interview how to ask questions how to
promote yourself online we've got some
nice sirens in the background here so
when it comes to figuring out how to
approach the job search how to reduce
your anxiety how to reach out to people
and how to perform well under pressure
that's the stuff that we're going to be
talking about pretty substantially today
we can also touch on some of the
technical things at a high level
including white boarding and things of
that sort and then if you have super
technical questions we'll be helping
each other out in the chat as well as in
slack in general with other Udacity
students so please bring all your
questions and we'll filter through them
and answer them as we go through this
discussion today
all right we got Cairo and Pakistan and
it is about five after so we're going to
be jumping on in thank you again for
everyone who is coming back to it a
second or third or fourth section and a
huge shout out to all of our new viewers
if you are new to this ask a career
coach session the way this works is you
ask questions we answer them is pretty
straightforward put them in the chat and
we'll be getting to your answers over
the next hour so our first question
today what we're going to kick off with
is this question of how should I
approach the phone interview and really
this is about behavioral interviews in
general we have a lot of anxiety when it
comes to different things around the
interview whether it's trying to come
off as impressive trying to remember our
answers were forward trying to you know
maybe showcase a level of expertise that
we don't necessarily have all sorts of
different things happen while you're
interviewing that you know make it
difficult and so that's one of the
things I want to dig into as we start
this conversation today so if you have
any interview related questions
behavioral or phone interview related
questions put them in the chat right now
and it will help shape shape to the
beginning of our discussion here but the
first thing I'm going to dig into is how
do you approach a phone interview now
there are lots of different types of
interviews that are technical interviews
there are in-person interviews that are
phone interviews that are video
interviews give a shout in the comments
if you've had to do a phone interview
before most of us have and there's two
kinds of phone interviews there's the
really video interview what we're doing
right now this kind of a thing and so
when you're thinking about getting ready
for this stuff there's a lot of basic
tactics that you just need to keep in
mind and a lot of times what ends up
happening is we fail to think through
the small things we spend so much time
thing about our resume and thinking
about you know power to answer questions
and all these seven things that we just
forget about the basics and that can
really catch you off guard if you don't
prepare ahead of time so a couple of
things I want to lay out as you're
getting ready for a phone interview is
that you want to do your system check
and what your system check is is
something we actually do before every
one of these calls and I actually messed
it up today I have the volume up on my
phone where I've got the youtubes going
and you could hear me in the background
you want to make sure that number one
your phone is in a place you and your
phone are in a place that has good
signal if your apartment is constantly
dropping calls don't take the call in
your apartment you also want to be away
from noise so don't take a phone
interview at a Starbucks
they've got music playing in the
background they've got all sorts of
things and a lot of what I'm going to
say here sounds pretty basic sounds
pretty self-explanatory but you would be
surprised to see how many people get
stuck in a situation or don't think
ahead and end up having to go through
these troublesome situations so what you
want to do is you want to make sure
you're in a place with great signal
whether that's for a phone or a video
interview if it's video you need to have
solid Wi-Fi if it's phone you need have
a solid signal on your phone you don't
want to take a video call on your phone
it's gonna be shaky it's gonna be
breaking in and out it's just not as
good so you use a computer for video use
your phone for phone next what you're
gonna want to do is you're going to want
to have a notepad ready and on that note
pad write down the name of the person
that you're interviewing with write down
the position that they have at the
company write down the job that you're
applying for just in case you have like
a little brain fart and you forget what
job you apply for you know you've been
looking all these
different job titles you might say the
wrong one by accident write down a list
of questions that you want to ask maybe
five or six questions that you want to
ask at the end of the interview that you
can have ready on standby when they say
we'd like to you know open it up for
questions for the last ten minutes and
then have a note section for you to be
writing things down during the
conversation and this notes section is
very important because when you send
your 24-hour follow-up you're going to
want to include some idea or some little
tidbit of something that you mentioned
or talked about in that interview in
your follow-up it's just a really great
way to sort of recall something that was
a good talking point or reinforce
something you want them to remember
about your conversation now another
thing that's really helpful to do if
you're on a video interview have a tab
open with your resume or print it out I
think it's depending you know we live in
a digital age so a lot of times it's
just at the tab but if you have a
printed version that's even better
also have a tab open with the job
description maybe write down a couple
things from that job description that
you miss want to make sure you mentioned
in the interview into your notes your
notepad or have them highlighted on the
screen also you want to maybe even have
the LinkedIn of the person you're
talking to pulled up that could help you
know put a face to the voice that you're
hearing in your ears if it's not a video
of its phone call so all of these things
will help you just set a solid baseline
to get started for the interview so that
you're not fumbling over paper trying to
find things or you know blinking any
time through your conversation and then
a couple of things if you are doing a
phone interview well I guess if you're
doing a video interview as well so I
have a standing desk here so all of my
videos that I try to do I try to be
standing because standing portrays much
more confidence than sitting or
slouching or like you know being on a
couch or something like that
so if you have the opportunity to be
standing during a video interview it
might be helpful of course sitting is
pretty standard so don't worry about it
either way
but if you are doing a phone interview I
would highly recommend walking around
while you're or standing or walking
while you're having that conversation it
brings more energy into the call and it
really helps the person on the other end
feel your energy feel your excitement if
you're just sitting slouched over it's
kind of interesting that your body
language can come through in a voice
call and so if you're standing if you're
smiling people can actually hear you
smile through the phone these are all
very weird little things that you just
might not think about until you've done
it a couple times you go out really
walking around the room made me much
more comfortable oh I didn't feel so
like trapped in my chair so these are a
few things as you're getting ready for a
phone interview that I'd like you to
keep in mind in order to just make sure
that you're portraying the correct
amount of or you're really putting out
the correct amount of energy and focus
and you have all your resources that you
need at hand so that you don't get stuck
at any point during that conversation if
you've prepped ahead of time you'll
always be in a better position all right
now we're going to be done sorry now
we're going to be diving into your
questions and I assume some of these
will be about the phone interview some
of these will be about pitching
different things of that sort and we'll
be getting into it right now
all right our first question comes from
Abhishek I apologize if I'm
mispronouncing your name not the best at
pronunciation at this point in time how
do I get a phone interview thank you so
much for your question you get a phone
interview the same way you get any
interview and the crazy thing to realize
is that 80% of jobs are found through
networking not through online job boards
so that means maybe 20% are found
throughout my job boards or other means
but 80% are found through people that
you know so how do you get an interview
if you don't know anyone who works these
companies well you have to go meet the
people who work for these companies so
what you want to do is start by
practicing informational interviews an
informational interview is an interview
that's not about any one specific job
it's about learning about a role about
an industry and about a person who you
want to you know maybe get some insights
from so what you can do and we've talked
about this on previous chants is you can
go to LinkedIn and do a people search in
your area for people who have the job
title that you wish you had and then you
can set up informational interviews if
you're curious of what an informational
interview is in more depth go to the
muse calm and just search it on their
site there's hundreds of articles that
will walk you through the ins and outs
of how to get one what to ask during one
it cetera etc but the key thing here is
that you want to make sure you're going
on informational interviews and
networking I like to take people out to
coffee that's my preferred way to
network and while you're doing that
while you're going on these coffees
you're doing a couple of things you're
learning about this job you're learning
about industries that you could work in
you're learning about the people that
have this job and how they think what
they struggle with what they're excited
about and so on and you're practicing
interview skills so when you actually
get to a phone interview or get
to an in-person interview you're going
to be 10 times more confident because
we've already talked about these topics
of someone in a low risk low stress
situation interview is high risk high
stress right you only get one shot at an
interview you get lots of shots at
networking informational interviews so
how do you get a phone interview you
meet people at the company you take them
out for an informational interview and
then at the end of that informational
interview you want to ask them a couple
of questions who else would you
recommend that I chat with and number
two in the future if the job opening
word if a job up in the future if a job
opening word to come up would you be
open to sending my resume or passing
along my resume this is not a direct ask
of do it right now it's a future ask so
the person is more likely to say yeah
sure if anything comes up just let me
know then you know you set a reminder on
LinkedIn of or indeed or wherever and
when a job does eventually come up a
week a month later that's when you can
reach back out and say it was really
great chatting with you at that
informational interview I really
appreciated our conversation this role
just came up would you still be open to
passing along my resume and you've
already gotten a pre commitment this is
actually a pretty big marketing sales
term but you've already had them pre
commit to the action so they are much
more likely to actually do it rather
than reaching out to a stranger who
you've never met saying here's my resume
would you pass it along if you've never
met the person don't assign them
homework if you've already met them had
a good conversation and asked permission
then you can ask them to refer you it
and that's really going to be the way
that you end up getting a phone
interview rather than you know
anywhere six months you need to do a
combination of the two the job boards
and the network combined to let you know
what companies need your help and then
you reach out and find your way all
right ash in number two Phyllis has a
question about liking to think first
before giving an answer how do I do this
on a phone interview how do I give
myself time to think
instead of saying um and all those
different things well I think the first
thing to do here Phyllis is cut yourself
a little bit of slack almost everyone
says um and like and all these different
things whenever I go back and I listen
to these recordings I'm saying um
constantly and so we just want to give
ourselves a little bit of slack because
we're not you know professional
interviewers it's not our job to be
professional interviewers right and that
is actually a job right like people have
podcasts and things like that it say I'm
doing it right now
now I'm thinking about my us oh my god
if you really need time to think about
an answer because yeah the alternative
is to just you know anxiously jump into
talking about something and then you
you're on a rant about something that
you didn't even want to talk about in
the first place when they ask you a
question you can calmly say hmm that's a
great question let me think about that
for a second give yourself 10 seconds or
five seconds maybe 10 seconds will feel
too long give yourself two to five
seconds to just go in your mind what is
a good story what is a good example that
I can use to answer this question and
most people can empathize with X we've
all been on interviews we've all wanted
a second to think and so if you just say
that's a great question give me a second
I mean I want to make sure I get the
right I want to make sure I think of the
right or the best possible response for
you and so then you give yourself a
second and your response this is
something that happens all the time but
then again
if you say um you know don't beat
yourself up in the moment it's okay to
say um to save some time because that's
really what we're trying to do when we
say um we're trying to think of the next
thing the UM the likes it's it's trying
to delay so our brain can can get over
that little skip that it's doing and get
back on track so give yourself a little
bit of slack on this one and probably
the best thing to do would be to go home
take a list of like top 30 interview
questions and just record yourself
answering those questions on your phone
and listen back to it and then when
you're listening back you'll hear all
the UM Xand the lights and the tangents
that you went on and then what you can
do is you can go through rerecord
yourself and answer them again
with the same answers and you'll get
more sharp with those answers then do it
again and you'll be more sharp and do it
again you'll be more sharp and then when
you actually get to the real interview
and this is why I think informational
interviews are good because you'll be
doing the same thing there you'll have
heard these stories so many times and
said these stories so many times that
bill flow up you know flow from your
brain much easier and you won't stumble
so much so that's one thing you can do
to reduce the um and be more confident
in the answers that you give alright our
next question is from Andreas what are
typical questions or cases that you
should expect to answer during your
interview this is a great question
Andreas the best thing you can do here
is go to I mean you can just Google or
go to the muse or go to any any career
website and look up typical interview
questions and you'll get you know 30 50
100 the top thousand best interview
questions right and the interesting
thing is most people who are
interviewing you aren't professional
interviewers they are people who are
managers or associates or whatever it is
and they're like oh we need someone to
help you know interview some new
candidates do you have time and what
person's gonna do is go to Google and
look up what question should I ask when
interviewing a candidate and you're
gonna have the same list that they have
because Google is gonna serve up the
same results so you can actually trust
these lists pretty well now certain
companies will throw you curveballs
they'll say do a case study or do some
crazy thing and you can also Google like
different types of case studies and how
to prepare and then other things that
you can do are you know what are the
things that you want to communicate
right there's two ways to answer
questions one wait for the question to
come in like I am here and then try an
answer to the best of your ability with
a bunch of M's and likes and things like
that or go in with the stories you
already want to tell and relate your
stories back to their questions so let's
say you have a story about a project
that you worked on that you are really
proud of you know I built this app using
this API with this team that
accomplished this result now if they ask
you what's the time that you worked well
with other team members you can say
there is this one app that I built using
this API I worked with these team
members and you double down on that part
of the story and we got this result and
then later they'll say what's a ton that
you struggled with the co-worker and
you'll say well while working on that
project that I've already mentioned
there was one co-worker in particular
whose name was Johnny and Johnny and I
just didn't see eye-to-eye on how to
solve this one particular issue so now
you're just going deeper into that story
from a different perspective and then
you can relate and we still were able to
complete the project and get this
outcome so when you're thinking about
this thing you really only need like
three to five stories that are good
because you can talk about strengths
weaknesses conflict collaboration all
these things with just a handful of
stories so go through your rolodex in
your head what were the times where I
really enjoyed my job what were the
projects that I really enjoyed working
on what were the hardest things I ever
did in my career what were those moments
that can really come up in a lot of
different answers to these questions and
then again go back to that idea of
recording yourself and listening to
yourself that's how you can really start
to practice these things but typical
questions will be around your strengths
your weaknesses it
examples of management experience
examples of things you've built and the
list goes on and on the key thing to
remember here though is that it's you
want to think about the question behind
the question now they might say what are
your strengths and weaknesses but really
what they're saying is how are you going
to fit into this team are you self-aware
do you understand that there's things
that you're trying to develop and how
are you developing those things just
saying my strengths it my strengths is
that I try too hard or something like
that doesn't show them how you work
through problems how you build your
self-awareness different things of that
sort
so always try and see what the question
is behind the question and the same goes
with like tell me about yourself when
they say tell me about yourself you're
not suppose to talk about you know your
vacation with your family last year
you're supposed to talk about things
that are relevant to them they want to
know why you're talking to them why are
we in a room together what is it that we
are aligned on and what are we trying to
accomplish are we on the same page those
are the questions that they're trying to
ask you they just use the you know
generic ones from the internet rather
than asking questions all right now
is from Sunita how can I answer
positively when I get a question that
I'm not sure how to answer this is a
really interesting question and I'll be
honest I'm not sure how to answer it
there's a few different things that you
can do one give your best answer what do
you think they are trying to ask you and
what is the best possible answer that
you could give them the other thing is
if you have never had experience with
something let's say so it's like tell me
about the time that you've worked with
XYZ programming language right and
you've never worked at that programming
language how do you answer them
positively well there's the negative way
to answer which is I've never worked at
that and then there's just as awkward
silence in the interview right it's like
well that's not the best way to answer
it right you always want to answer with
a positive spin of some sort right so
well I've never worked at that language
specifically however these are the
languages that I'm familiar with and
here's how I learned them and here's
what I've done with the information that
I have so when I was learning Java the
first thing I did was XYZ and I'm now
able to build these types of things with
that knowledge I would do the same thing
when learning you know whatever the
other thing Python is or whatever the
other thing is right and and you're
relating something you have done with
the thing that they're asking you about
so that's another way to answer it and
then worst case scenario let's say is
something so far out of the realm that
you don't have any experience and you
don't know how to answer and you don't
have any stories that relate then you
just say actually that's something that
I'm not really familiar with at this
time but it sounds like a really
exciting area to get into do you have
any recommendations of how I could get
up to speed quickly in that area and now
you're again answering by saying I don't
really have an answer but you're asking
for help you're showing that you're
gonna do something after this
conversation rather than just accept the
fact that you don't know it and go home
I don't know move on to the next thing
so one cool thing about that and this I
think a great example of this is let's
say you do a whiteboard interview and
you get the wrong answer what do you do
next
most people go home kick themselves
because they got the wrong answer
don't write a thank-you note because
they don't want to hear back negative
news and then turn on Netflix and try to
distract themselves someone else who's
trying to really build themselves and
grow as a person would go home try and
think of what the question was that they
asked maybe do a little bit more work
see if they can solve it again on their
own or do a little bit more research
into that area and then send a follow-up
thank-you note within 24 hours that says
hey it was a real pleasure chatting with
you today you know after our
conversation when I hit that wall during
the whiteboarding when I hit that wall
during the whiteboarding peace it really
showed me that I needed to learn more
about X Y Z so when I got home today I
looked up this and I read that and I
tried this and I wanted to share that
with you and just say thank you so much
for having me in I really enjoyed the
conversation I'd love to continue it and
see see what the next steps are that's
how you always be a proactive rather
than a reactive person in your
interviews and in your job search so try
and always approach things from a much
more positive action-oriented way and
you'll be putting yourself in a very
successful position all right
sunny I've got a phone interview in a
few days there's a requirement in the
role that I don't have experience with
what should I answer when asked about
this requirement this is a great
question because a couple of things come
up pop out to me the first one is that
job descriptions are typically an I like
an idealized list of the perfect
candidate so they will include
everything in the kitchen sink in there
when they create that list they'll say I
want someone who has two to five years
experience for
entry-level job I want someone who knows
every single language I want someone who
you know can build things from scratch
I'd be an entrepreneur and so on and so
forth what they're trying to do when
they build a Job Description is cast a
wide net and most people unfortunately
according to you know recent statistics
won't apply to a job that they don't
have 100% of the qualifications for but
what they don't understand is that no
one has 100% of the qualifications for
any of these jobs and if you were 100%
qualified for that job you shouldn't be
applying for that job you should be
applying for the senior version of that
job so if you only meet like 60% 70% of
the requirements in the job listing it's
still worth applying to then if they ask
you about let's say a programming
language that you're not familiar with
you can talk about how quickly you're
able to learn programming languages you
can maybe do a little bit of research on
that programming language before you go
in and say you know I saw that in the
job listing and I started reading this
book in that thing and doing this and
I'm really curious like do you have any
recommendations of how I could you know
learn this faster or are there any
people at the company I could talk to to
really get up to speed as quickly as
possible because it's really exciting
and I love learning these things right
so address it in a way that shows that
you're doing something rather than just
accepting the fact that you don't have
that skill so you've got a few days try
and just do some basic research so you
at least know what each one of those
things are if they go in and they ask
you something and you're like I've never
even heard of that before
that's going to be a little bigger of an
issue but if it's in the job listing
you've heard of it so now just do some
basic research all right our next
is from Karthik I have an interview this
week for a research position internship
and we'll be taking and we'll be talking
with a leading scientist but this is my
first interview helped me how can I make
sure I impress them alright so this idea
of impressing people is what really gets
to the core of our anxieties in the job
search and the truth of the matter is is
that when you go in for an interview
being impressive is less impressive than
being curious so if you go in and you
try to be a know-it-all no one wants to
work with a know-it-all
no one wants to work with someone who
comes in day one and says I know all the
answers I'm not gonna ask any questions
do what I say cancel these projects
you're doing it wrong do it like this no
one wants to work with that person even
if they're right people want to work
with the person who's curious the person
who says why are we doing it this way
you know what led us to doing it this
way are there any other things that
we've explored how did they work you
know have we thought about how this new
technology might be beneficial have we
tried it have we tested it would have
been the results people want to talk to
curious people not necessarily someone
who just thinks they have all the
answers
so as you're prepping for this interview
there's probably a ton of things that
this scientist knows that you would love
to know right they are probably you know
way ahead of you in their career they
probably have a ton of experience of a
lot of different technologies they
probably have their pulse on the future
of the industry when you go in ask them
about them make it less about you if you
can get someone talking about things
that are excited about they're gonna be
excited they're gonna leave that
conversation feeling good about this
conversation and so you know you want to
be clear and concise in the answers that
they ask you and then you want to ask
them about things that they care about
if you do those two things if you be
clear and concise and you can be curious
you're gonna really stand out from the
pack so I hope you give yourself a
little bit of slack
go online look up good questions to ask
during an interview and go back to what
we said before of practicing your
answers before you get there don't go in
without an idea of what you're what
you're hoping to say you know again go
back through your list of projects that
you've worked on in the past what did
you enjoy what did you struggle with
where are you currently trying to grow
those are the things that are going to
really make you stand out if you can
show that you are a lifelong learner and
that you are curious you're going to be
in a really great spot all right again
thank you everyone for submitting your
questions here we've got really good
ones coming in so if you have something
on your mind and you're feeling hesitant
just put it in I'm gonna try and get to
as much as I can in the next half hour
all right our next one Gregory hey
Martin I've done a couple of phone
interviews recently 10-plus with
recruiters about roles in the
self-driving car industry some
recruiters keep focusing on my current
job which is not related about what -
which is not related to what I'm looking
for which is software implementation
specialists versus deep learning
perception engineer and I think they see
me as a professional with no experience
in the field
even if I've gained the skills from the
self-driving car nanodegree I'm
wondering if I need to refocus my
research on more entry-level roles or
find a better or find a way to better
explain my career move to these
recruiters let me know your thoughts all
right Greg there's a number of things
that stand out here the first thing is
that you're talking to recruiters and
not people who are working in the job
that you want or hiring managers so
recruiters have a very tough job their
job is to sift through thousands of
people to find the best person for their
client who's not you you're not their
client the client is the company that
hired them to fill the role so when they
reach out to you they're only asking
about your past experience because
that's all they can verify when they go
and pitch you to the company and so they
really only want to pitch sure things to
the company they don't want to go to the
company with people who might be good or
people who are working towards being
good they want to go to the company with
someone who has history with a big
company history with a good like you
know prestigious school history with a
certain technology for a long period of
time they want sure things they are not
going to risk their reputation on a
maybe so when you're thinking about
working with recruiters you have to
realize that if you want them to pitch
you correctly you have to pitch them on
what you want now this is tough because
recruiters are trying to deal with
thousands of people you know so I
personally think your time will be
better spent reaching out to people who
work at the company and trying to find
your way in through networking rather
than through a recruiter it doesn't mean
recruiters are bad and it doesn't mean
that they can't be helpful it just means
that what you're experiencing right now
is something that I hear oh well I mean
fight it all you want but they're trying
to get answers they're not trying to
learn about your life story right and
again some of them are very good people
and there are some of them they're good
people and they want to know about you
and they want to be able to pitch you
but at the end of the day they're
they're just dealing with such vast
numbers of people you know so either you
make it easy for them by creating a
personal brand that is so focused on the
new thing you want to be doing that they
can really validate your skill set based
off of your online presence and not have
to worry about the company saying this
person doesn't seem qualified or you
need to find another way in
so that would be my recommendation here
try not to put try not to outsource your
job search to anyone other than yourself
you're in control of your job search
you're in control of your network you're
in control of reaching out to people and
getting interviews if you try to give
that to someone else because you don't
want to do the networking work you're
going to get the results that you're
getting so
keep that in mind keep moving forward
you know when you do talk to them just
say I'm trying to move into this
direction and they'll either be on board
with it or they won't and then you can
move on to the next recruiter or the
next networking conversation that you
can have thank you so much for your
question
all right here we go Karla I'm a former
IT teacher with eight years of
experience I am looking for a position
as a developer and I'm not sure about
what to answer when they ask how many
years of experience that I have some
advice I love this question Perla all
right experience experience is a loaded
question
right I talked to people all the time
who are like I don't have any experience
in you know front-end development yet
they've had experience in four or five
jobs and they've been in the mark in the
job in there they're about 10 to 12
years into their career so experience
means different things to different
people it means something to you it
means something to the person you're
talking to different hiring managers
that different companies will expect it
to mean different things it's really
hard to know what a company is looking
for when it comes to experiments now we
might want to say oh the job says I need
two to five years of experience that
means two to five years of experiencing
this very specific role but oftentimes
that isn't the case a lot of companies
will interview people that have
experience in slightly related roles in
slightly different roles they look at
your education is really about the whole
package right you got to look at
everything you've done and the big thing
that I want to emphasize here is do not
discount your experience do not say
because I was a teacher I'm not my
experience isn't relevant for this new
role because everyone's experience is
relevant in some way shape or form my
marketing experience has helped me as a
coach that's why we've got these videos
going on so everything you've done
builds on itself and everything you've
done has a skill associated with it as
collaboration skills as you know
execution skills has technical skills as
there's all soft skills hard skills
everything that goes into it so when
someone says how much experience do you
have you can actually break it down for
them don't just say I only have one you
know six months of experience in my
nanodegree say
in my past I have I started my career
doing this I was a teacher with eight
years of experience in IT which has
given me a really great perspective on
how to work with people how to educate
people how to not only execute but
inform my management on how I get things
done
etc etc and then say and I've added to
that experience my nano degree and my
side projects and my internships and and
my other work so it's all about framing
it as an evolution and building a little
like you know I mean I don't know like a
Lego wall of your experience right so
all these pieces come together over time
and they all add up to being your
experience so if you're being asked this
question just talk about that full
picture I've had experience of this I've
had experience of this of experience of
this and they all combine to be about 12
years of overall experience and I'm
really excited to bring this experience
to your companies like help you solve
problems and do XY and Z relate it back
to what they need and that's really
going to show that your background
connects with the future that you want
which is this role with this company
all right this next question is a big
one a mirror iwi believe I'm pronouncing
it right a mirror
I have an interview soon but I want to
reschedule to study more and be more
prepared should I do that or would that
leave a bad impression
I really appreciate this question it's
one that comes up not only with like
scheduled interviews but also with take
home like assignments and things of that
sort you never ever want to reschedule
your interview unless there is some sort
of family emergency or other thing that
comes up rescheduling your interview
does a number of negative things in the
process it shows that you can't hit a
deadline which is really bad when trying
to get a job it shows that you don't
honor your commitments also really bad
when applying for a job and it puts you
at a disadvantage because in the time
that you are giving you know let's say
you reschedule it for a week out first
of all how much more you're gonna learn
in the next week than what you know
right now probably not a ton so unless
you're scheduling it out for another
year where you're gonna go learn a new
language or something you're probably
not gonna get much out of that week but
then what is really gonna do is just put
you at a disadvantage because they're
gonna start bringing in other people
you're gonna say I'll talk to you next
week and they're gonna say all right in
the next week we're gonna interview five
more people and now you've got five more
people that you're competing with for
that job do not reschedule your
interviews make them work and this also
goes for take-home interviews I recently
was working with someone who had a take
home interview they reached out on like
a Monday and they said hey let us know
when you're able to do this take-home
interview and they said I can do it on
Thursday right again you're giving too
many days for other people to be turning
in their assignment who's gonna look
better the person who got reached out
on Monday and turns it in on Tuesday or
the person that got reached out to on
Monday and turns it in on Friday or the
next Monday clearly the person who gets
it in within the day and they're also
going to be considered sooner and and
first when you want to limit the number
of people who can cut in front of you in
line so do not put off an interview do
not put off your stuff you you know own
where you're at in the process move
forward and go after it at the very
worst you're going to learn something
and you'll be ready for the next
interview at the very best you'll be the
first person that they talk to and
they're gonna go that was a really great
conversation let's keep moving forward I
really appreciate that question that's a
hard one and I understand I I like I
feel for you it it doesn't feel good to
not feel ready but this is where you got
to step up and take ownership and say
what do I know what don't I know I'm
gonna own what I know I'm gonna learn as
much as I can about what I don't know
and then I'm gonna figure out how to
talk about what I don't know if they ask
me about it in the interview like we
talked about earlier in this
conversation all right al ala has our
next question famous question from
almost every employer they always ask
why do you want to work for us what
would be the best response I love this
al thank you so much for asking this
question this is something that comes up
a lot when I'm trying to coach people I
always sit down and I talked to people
and we've actually made a couple videos
about this and I say where do you want
to work what industry and what company
and inevitably everyone says I want to
work in tech which is everything now
everything is tech there isn't a single
industry that's not tech I mean I'm
watching woodworking videos on Instagram
so instagrams tech they're doing
woodworking clearly it's a tech company
right Biff do e-commerce somehow
everything is tech so that's a
non-answer and then they say they want
to work at it Facebook Google and
whatever the other Tesla right
and I say why and usually the answer is
well because it's Facebook Google and
Tesla duh why wouldn't I want to work
there and of course why wouldn't you
want to work there but why would you
want to work there other than the brand
name and the money like if the only
reason you want to work at this company
is because it helps you
why should this company want you that's
the big question right so if I only want
to work with this company because it
helps put a big brand name on my resume
and you know gives me money to go spend
on the weekends and that company asks me
well why do you want to work here and I
just say because it will it'll look good
on me bill are gonna be like well what
are you gonna do for us
we're the ones paying you we're the ones
giving you all that value are you gonna
give us anything back so you really have
to ask yourself why why Google why
Facebook my favorite twist on this was I
had a student who wanted to work at
Amazon and they said I want to work at
Amazon because it's Amazon I said where
would you want to work within Amazon and
we got down to they want to work on the
voice systems right the I want to say
Alexa and then she'll talk in the
background so I asked why well they have
a background in linguistics and they're
really and they're currently a
programmer and they're really interested
in the merger of language spoken
language and programming languages
well now we're cooking with fire right
now we can say alright so we can put
Amazon on your list that can be the
center of the of the map now what other
companies work with voice foam companies
other tech companies car companies
little robot AI companies right there
are so many companies working on voice I
mean hearing aid companies there's all
sorts of different things and that
really broadens out the scope so you're
not so hyper focused on any one company
you're focused on improving language
improving the language barrier between
people and machines and that was that
what they ended up them in the end of
chasing that and so when they
and get asked by any of these companies
why do you want to work here well I have
a background in linguistics I'm super
fascinated by the interaction of humans
and machines and I think voice is going
to be the key component there your
company is working on doing that in cars
and I'm really excited to help you can
build more human systems that can
interact more seamlessly with the
passengers in the cars boom that's a
great answer if they went to Tesla and
said well it's Tesla and you're you know
you got an interesting founder and those
flamethrowers at the boring company were
cool like this is a bad answer so I
would say they're you know I don't have
a best response for you but I would ask
yourself what do you actually care about
what are the industries that you think
will make an impact in the world that
you're interested in being part of you
know if you are really interested in
sports technology you can talk about
being introduced to sports by your you
know dad as a kid maybe you went to
baseball games together or something
like that if you're really interested in
video games you can talk about you know
the world building and the storytelling
and different things like that if you're
really interested in media you can talk
about how communication is the best way
to you know change people's minds at a
world level right worldwide level and so
all these different things play into why
you want to do what you're doing and so
really take a look at what you enjoy
about the technology you're working with
the work you're doing and ask yourself
well if this were to be blown out to the
biggest level is this something that I
care about and that's gonna be how you
answer why you want to work at that
company and again it could be their
mission it could be well you this
company works on AI and I think yeah is
really interesting maybe it's technology
focused but everyone you should have a
reason if you're just applying to a
company because you want a job and you
want money I'm sorry it's just a bad
pitch and so we got to really think a
little bit deeper and say beyond the
money let's say you had two jobs that
both offered the same amount of money
and the same amount of prestige but one
worked on you know self-driving cars
that will reduce driving deaths around
the world and the other one sold
cigarettes which would you be more
interested in working at
and why right and so you can kind of
work your way back from what don't I
want into what I what do I want if you
really don't know where to start
so hopefully that helps get the wheels
turning a little bit all right we had
about ten minutes I'm trying to move as
quickly as I can through these questions
but we do have quite a few I thank you
again for submitting all these great
questions mmm I'm going to try and find
some of the more Universal ones here too
to wrap us up today all right this next
one because it relates to a video I just
posted earlier today Abdul Rahman is
linked in a must for an interview I put
my work on github and rarely use
LinkedIn and other social platforms what
disadvantages can that give me love this
question so there's a few things to
think about here not having a LinkedIn
at all is a big red flag because then
they say it's like not having a resume
it's like well why why not like it takes
two seconds to just create the account
put your face on it and and and whatever
now I have run into situations where
people don't do it for security reasons
maybe they work for the government and
they aren't allowed to maybe they
actually had someone who had a stalker
and they were like I can't have a
LinkedIn I was like well that's a fair
reason that's a pretty good reason not
to have a LinkedIn and then I had
someone who you know worked in data
security and they said I don't like
LinkedIn they don't like Facebook but
now that's part of their pitch I don't
have a LinkedIn a Facebook because I
work in security and I think those are
those websites lack security and that's
a really interesting thing so they have
to find people off those sites now it's
possible to get a job without a LinkedIn
I'm not going to say it's completely
impossible but boy does it help when you
had one it helps because you there's two
things that happen with LinkedIn number
one companies can find you the first
thing I'm going to do when I interview
someone is Google them and usually the
first result that comes up is their
LinkedIn
if they don't have a personal site if
they don't have a blog if they're not on
YouTube etc their LinkedIn is typically
what comes up first if nothing comes up
and I'm going in blind
it makes it just a harder way to get to
know someone and so what you can do with
these websites by having them is make it
easier for someone to feel like they
already know you before we talk that's
the whole point to feel like we already
have a connection before we sit down it
reduces anxiety on both sides and
everyone's a little bit happier now if
you have a LinkedIn it doesn't have to
be the best profile in the world we
actually did tests on this to go from no
LinkedIn at all to at least having a
LinkedIn with basic information on it
huge spike in P in hiring managers
wanting to talk to that person now
having basic information versus robust
information kind of levels out a little
bit you know the the graph kind of evens
out a little bit so just get the basics
in and you should be fairly good but I
really will say the disadvantage is that
you just don't get the visibility
imagine if Nike refused to go on social
media we would forget that they sell
shoes eventually because that's where
the conversation is so you need to be
part of the conversation so what I would
recommend if you want to increase your
chances and be seen more is to comment
on people's profiles write articles
share links because that will keep your
face popping up in the feet a lot of you
know me from these videos know me from
the career tip videos that we've been
doing on LinkedIn and YouTube and I
can't tell you how many opportunities
and interesting conversations come out
of those things just just more people to
talk to more data points more Commons
more feedback like you'll learn a lot by
engaging in these platforms I it I would
say it's as important as a resume so at
least have the basics there at least
copy your resume onto LinkedIn because
it's a digital resume at the most basic
version so I would highly recommend you
do that also give
doesn't show up on Google as easily as
LinkedIn doesn't rank as high for some
reason alright and we're getting into
the last four minutes here so before we
wrap up I want to do a couple of things
the first thing I want to do is promote
a webinar that's coming up called
succeeding as a freelancer we're gonna
link it in the chat here and I highly
recommend that if any of you are trying
to find contract work or just trying to
build your own thing or do some projects
to sign up for that webinar it's gonna
be really great it's on to 26 and it's
just gonna be a great time for anyone
who's really curious about that area the
next thing I want to promote is that we
do these every single Thursday so please
share these with anyone you know go
register for the next one I believe
we'll be putting the link in the chat as
well invite friends to come join this
next time and these are also recorded
and kept up on YouTube if you ever want
to come back and check out our
conversation again so feel free to come
back rewatch it put some comments in and
help each other out the key thing here
is like this community this ability for
us to help each other out and connect is
so vital in order to keep these things
moving and you know there's so many
things that I just don't know the answer
to so some of you can probably help each
other so I really appreciate you
engaging with each other connecting with
each other after these I know a lot of
people go to LinkedIn and connect and
now you're part of each other's network
helping each other out like eh
so please go do that
and then we have two minutes left I'm
gonna try and answer one more question
and see what we got here
all right how six all right our last
question from Ryan how successful our
informational interviews via a phone
call or video call you may be looking
for work and if you may be working if
you are looking for work in another
country
honestly 10 years ago I would have said
it's really difficult but we live in a
very very connected world and video is
becoming easier and easier and easier
hangouts Skype zoom all these things
make it incredibly easy to do video
interviews and phone interviews so I
actually think that there's you know the
best possible thing would be a 3d
in-person meeting course but I think
that video calls and phone calls you can
get a lot of distance out of these
technologies I can tell you I've been
hired for jobs just through the internet
so the key thing is how do you practice
them when you're not interviewing right
we're not typically you know calling up
our friends and saying let's Skype I
mean some people do they live it you
know they moved away they live for far
from people um but I would encourage you
to take some time in the coming months
to set up maybe some Skype calls with a
family member or a friend just to get
familiar with the technology because
there's a lot of glitching that happens
on hangouts and zoom and Skype there's a
lot of weird stuff that happens so if
you're looking for work and you know
you're gonna have to do phone interviews
and big video interviews try and get a
little practice using these different
platforms and different technologies
it'll really help set you up for success
so that you're not fumbling with links
or trying to figure out how to join a
call or create an account or update your
skype that's a key thing updating Skype
is constantly wanting to update so
sometimes you'll be late to an interview
because it's refreshing itself test out
your systems try doing a few calls on
your own make sure you've got the basics
down and really at the end of the day
they are pretty successful we're moving
into a very remote
world which means lots of people are
getting very comfortable working like
this so I think they're pretty
successful personally and definitely
worthwhile getting to know thank you so
much for joining us today I'm gonna wrap
up right now again my name is Martin
McGovern if you'd like to connect with
me on LinkedIn after this and ask more
questions I'm happy to continue the
conversation there please connect with
each other
join us next week hit up that you know
how to freelance webinar and I look
forward to checking out more questions
from all of you next week
Abdulla
you